[Music]
in worst mother ever news submitted by I
said me more me Ahmad mmm on a woman was
jailed after killing her young daughters
who got in the way of her sex life sorry
to find I mean that's [ __ ] up
yeah that's why I got distracted I was
like wow this Mother's know you wanted
to mug it's like you don't see a sign
Miami and [ __ ] yet to emphasize LA and
sometimes LA I'm the Prince of Saudi
Arabia it's like you [ __ ] my husband
wait back to this crazy ass so yeah [ __ ]
this mother tried to kill her daughter
Lexi twice before ye before she of cuz
her daughter was too sexy and all of her
boyfriends were trying to [ __ ] her
daughter nope Oh her daughter was very
uh she's a baby
they're the mama trying to go out
clubbing why the [ __ ] are you here
crying closer so when her daughter was
ill in the hospital the week before she
died the mom took topless pictures in
the toilets and then arranged to perform
sex acts for money with men she met
online so she was a ho but I don't want
to judge around my daughter but they but
they're by their mother the daughter was
like crying in the other room and they
[ __ ] up the whole sex was that what it
was so he doesn't have the picture of
the kids in front you know yeah I don't
do it yet cuz I like to guess that's
when it makes her sad
yeah that's why I've already there I'm
supposed to block the screen but okay so
the this mom of two she describes
herself as a part-time model accepted 41
friend requests on a dating app just a
day after the murder
she's like I'm free now aren't and she
was later heard laughing at a funeral
part a funeral parlor two days before
she killed scarlet on February 4 oh man
this one's dog she's so horny she's a
bit of a horny lady so dark and the kid
was just too annoying that's that could
be so emergency emergency services said
that she was calm and emotionless
delaying her call for an ambulance and
even filling up with gas just with her
daughter laying in the car she's like
filling up the gas tank and there's
oh no not even sir sees that bakasur she
would do anything for her kids wait did
we say I was totally blacked out did
they say how the children that's a model
good - that she thinks she's a model
self-described mom oh yeah yeah she's
like she's all babies man babies that's
her those babies - cute picture and
that's her persona and so the kids
already oh [ __ ] man that's [ __ ] up
that's so we can make fun of her
appearance because she's a bad person
of course yeah she but I hope you don't
look like her out there as we make fun
of her she looks like one of those
people that like she's like oh I'm 25 I
don't look like my age ha and you're
like yeah you look 60 [ __ ] right you
look like a [ __ ] old hag and Hansel
and Gretel bro who where is a father a
father in the picture I'm assuming no he
is out of the picture
why does she have to queue dad's [ __ ]
kids her kids are really cute and both
of them to have I mean these pictures
killed basically during the trial it was
revealed by the prosecutor that the
evidence seems to be that Lexi and
Scarlett her two kids died because
someone deliberately interfered with
their breathing ha ha so the she choked
on no natural reason why they died it
was because of this hostess show guys
will [ __ ] anything she had ready to [ __ ]
her yeah she's disgusting and she got
paid to [ __ ] she should be paying them
to [ __ ] look at what she looks like yeah
man she's [ __ ] like should be getting
coupons out she's like the Hansel and
Gretel witch dude what the [ __ ]
oh no the kids are present when she's
having sex with these men like they're
getting in the way like that like she
felt like she couldn't go do what she
wanted to do know probably like here are
my two kids I'm trying to get a big you
got use goods or some [ __ ] I mean
I'm sure I'm assuming over here I was
getting good she's not getting high
clientele
I'm guessing smooth the kids so a lot of
people want to know where was the dad
during all this right yeah he was in
jail
oh no yeah he was he was not there he
was the pimp they're divorced he was in
the forever quest bar he he has dude he
is not at all involved in any of this
and that's what's so strange about it is
that he basically he released a victim
impact statement saying that he feels
broken has nothing to live for
but during all this [ __ ] he's not seen
heard like pictured none of it so he's
not part of the children's life like
he's Native day I don't think so so he
was absent well I will say this he's
probably gonna get a lot of heat for
being not present well you don't know
because she might have just taken the
kids and ran to she doing a single mom
so we don't really know what the
conditions are that kept the data maybe
maybe she threatened his life he's like
you know what her mouth I mean she's
obviously batshit insane yeah we really
don't know 41 people wrong
like that's Bob there's 41 guys that
were willing to [ __ ] her or do what my
dick turns into a vagina around her
let's get on tinder right now and see
how many people will get in our inbox in
24 hours I don't even know if I could
get 41 I think this would give us it
should help me this will help me what
you just post pictures of you and your
son like hanging out people like I love
this guy
have you gotten more attention since
having wearing the wedding I'm not the
type of person who thinks about getting
attention but I have noticed a couple
times when I'm wearing my ring it's
definitely like like some kind of a
thing as they say forbidden fruit man
it's pretty weird a woman goes after a
guy because he has a ring so I knew who
especially just like me all their
children but you have any sense the
ability or something so they want to
take someone else's stability I think
this is it's like unwritten of like
you're risking something so we'll play
by the whiteness that's the fun part
yeah oh yeah because it's like you have
a life that you have something to lose
whether you agree with that or not so I
guess there's a sense of you know safety
in some convoluted what I I do notice
though that if you are already around
women or like what like around them like
you have female friends or whatever
right automatically girls are more
willing to talk to you and everything
like it in a pin like you know
you're not weird in a public setting
that's what I love about it dude
I was just talking to Julia I don't know
like an hour or so ago and it's so
awesome just to get to talk to somebody
one one and not even worry about any
[ __ ] cuz they know I'm married I
know I'm married so it's not even a
[ __ ] thing
like it's so dope and freeing to just be
able to like talk to people and there's
no [ __ ] like when we all have family
like we all have like like JK family
get-togethers and [ __ ] we can all be
talking to anybody and nobody's weird
cuz we're no one's cuz we know it all
paired up correctly or you guys are just
having massive orgies or not that's what
everyone don't tell anybody about
situations where people aren't coupled
up or married you feel weird like
they're trying to [ __ ] you all day yeah
well if there's the single people then
they stand out really so thank you it
was just on our podcast and then she was
saying that so she used to do like a lot
of stand-up comedy in the stand-up
comedy circle it was her because like
there's not that many female incentive
comedy it's her and a bunch of other
comics and so she always thinking like
oh cool just riding joke trying to bits
together always hanging out and then
there's always friends something like No
all these dudes always trying to [ __ ]
you they're always trying to [ __ ] you
deals now they're not I have a boyfriend
we were all good buddies but every
single time when she has a new boyfriend
or like wouldn't they just break up all
of them want to [ __ ] her and they so
she's like [ __ ] how thirsty are these
dudes everyone son [ __ ] me like this
and there are guys who are trying to set
up who titrated there are guys we're
trying to set up their next move yeah
I'm saying so like you might be booed up
and [ __ ] but then they're trying to like
game their way into your club so much
work man they do backups and [ __ ] their
[ __ ] beads man cuz like they don't
want the garden to grow and then they
can pick any flower they choose
eventually yeah give it time give it
some work yeah what about just being
straight up it's it's not anything work
not very popular bunk guys girls even
amongst girls oh please say you know
they don't want you telling me the truth
you want to play dangerous
if you walk up to growing on here you're
cute let's go hey you look like an
interesting person would you like to
grab a meal or a coffee sometimes
interesting help yeah creepy I mean but
if you're single
I mean the interesting person you'll see
the inside weirdo no if I'm not LA
Fitness minding my own business you come
and talk to everybody huh
get away you're the most beautiful woman
I've ever seen in my entire life
you want to go running some time with me
what is that really your pickup move
that's we do I I'm pretty different I do
okay how'd you get her we met at a dance
charity event Zumba and you walked up
and kind of just had small talk and one
you know and then we you know yeah but
yeah no one ever does
no not no one but it's very rare that
you say like someone you compliment them
on their looks and then you actually get
with them you just talk to them you just
have a conversation no or top a deal and
then you're like just [ __ ] talk about
anything right and then and then you
actually become friends and then you
start hanging out in your life you know
what I think I can [ __ ] you or you slide
in the Davidi answer they just they just
[ __ ] send you a teeny pic and you're
just like ready to go I seen this guy
well I was talking to these girls and
tell you about this guy and he has this
technique where he lowers their guard by
saying that he's a recovering sex addict
and then that intrigues him and they're
like wait what was that lower guard oh
because they started asking questions
they're like wait wait so what do you
mean he's like did you worried about him
yeah and he's like you know like it
poison ivy sample he's like you
basically was like you know I have to
stop our date right now he's foreign to
his French so my French access for the
bad but pretty much he says you guys
have to be honest with you I'm a
recovering sex addict and I feel like
things are getting a little
right now so I'm gonna you know please
don't be offended by me back half wait
what do you mean like so tell me more
about it well you know I don't follow
any girls on Instagram because as soon
as I write their picture they'll DM me
and you know I've collected over two
thousand bodies out here in LA in itself
that's [ __ ] genius a body count too
and then he [ __ ] his check and he's a
dick
because the girl the girls now she
thinks she's a forbidden fruit it's just
like I don't want to be I don't want to
succumb help him with his addiction but
then it's so sexy you know addiction
everything a girl wants to hear too you
know he doesn't follow what half the
Instagram girls that are on the
Instagram like he doesn't he doesn't
jerk off the [ __ ] he doesn't do this I
don't want to show you this guy offline
I believe I believe every word he says
damn hey that's what says about you she
says that she she likes she like to and
to start with because you seem
mysterious mm-hmm we're not talking a
lot and [ __ ] and being the kind of quiet
area has an angle to it yeah but then it
gets you in a lot of trouble when you're
actually diverted and don't talk a whole
lot it's gotta be yourself because if
they don't fall for you for who you
actually are you gonna run into this
you're down the right now case you gotta
be something so you can't just be your
normal like sloppy self or whatever you
know your version is then you'll
naturally attract people who are
attracted to the poor man this guy that
you know who he does he have any inkling
to settle down I'm assuming no not like
I've heard like I've heard like the
other story because it was so weird I
was out I went to go get dinner and I
see some girls I knew I was oh hey
what's up so we sitting down and they
like in the middle of this conversation
so they started talking about this guy
and the next girl was like you know it's
crazy about that because I'm sure that
you know he's full of [ __ ] because what
he does is or she calls him out yeah she
shoot because she was gamed up
your home rose gamedev she says he says
the story to them so it buys some time
because he's dating like eight girls at
the same time so it buys him time in
between these chicks you know like oh
you know I feel bad for you tonight and
hopin this next one and this one will
come back her I was like damn this is it
he's a sex addict is this havoc yeah
yeah maybe he's telling the truth he's
telling the truth
okay just to cause this on a very
positive note this woman who killed her
kids sentenced to 32 years in prison
[ __ ]
okay right 32 year old she get life
though she get killed